[Music]
in hashtag millenium probs news Oh
submitted by please bring back Megan
heart me that's an actual submission
you didn't just write the hello I did I
saw her when people meet us out there
these fans out there they go I've heard
in both occasions what are you gonna
help me or when you come I have to me
but we like that I always hear same
person we like say them right afterwards
they will say that about all of our
gifts I tell you that and that's why
some of them don't come back they're too
busy for us and we really want them back
so they just don't want to sit no that's
not you I'm not busy enough a
millionaire sinks Millennials can't
afford houses because they eat too much
avocado - that's true oh [ __ ] love
avocados no why what here right now I'm
offended bobble coddled toast is bombed
oh oh is the top [ __ ] that is [ __ ]
picture is hits their ass [ __ ] right
my girlfriend orders one I can't abide
I'm like I wouldn't pay for it what's
avocados Oh
exactly what it sounds like avocados
salt done if you want to yeah and like
lemon olive oils and junkies with an egg
on it lemon is pharmacology Jamal and if
you want protein put a poached egg on
that [ __ ] yeah yeah
over a poached egg I never want to say
that Joey not over a poached egg but
like actually poached eggs are pretty
hard to make so when you get it right
yeah don't just buy fish it yeah Ellen I
like it she like sucks you need to try
it cuz I get it I think and that's the
first time I was like what is this I
know
caterpillar sir you can add a poached
egg vegetarian right yeah but they have
eggs
okay Lord's vegetarian right so
vegetarian has egg yeah do anything on
this Australian news show called 60
minutes there is the Australian
millionaire and property mogul named Jim
nut mug Australia millionaires are
pretty obnoxious though [ __ ] they're
pretty booked I got in a fight with one
my body was [ __ ] like the [ __ ] yeah
so when he was asked a question about
being able to afford like houses like
Millennials being able to afford houses
it's difficult and so for him he agrees
with the statement and he was just
saying you know when I was trying to buy
my first home I was implying smashed
avocado for $19 and for coffee for $4
each we're at a point now where the
expectations of younger people are very
very high they want to eat out every day
they want to travel to Europe every year
the people that own home today work very
hard very hard for it and saved every
dollar did everything they could to get
up to the property investment letter so
a lot of people blew out like Buddhist
statement out of proportion saying like
avocados are the actual reason why
millennial cattle babies but like that
was just his example of like well I mean
here's an example why Millennials kept
dated because they want to spend these
just yeah they want to eat absolutely -
yeah I think people know that though you
know like I'm pretty sure people aren't
like eating out all the time going - I
don't have a house is because this is
the lifestyle enjoy so it's hard to I'd
rather have the convenience of eating
out but I also know I'm not going to buy
a house soon because yeah like I think
people know that and at the same time
you can't assume that everyone sees a
house as an investment but really want
buy a house because they might not for
them and the way they do their taxes and
want to
of your life like it might not even be
an investment at all I don't know what
it's like in Australia land but out here
in Los Angeles land the real estate
market is like unbelievable you [ __ ]
get out of college start working and all
that stuff and even if you get married
within the first five years or within
the first ten years it's going to be
very very expensive to buy a home so
most people are like [ __ ] it let's just
be minimal let's just live in the city
get like a small little area like please
rent that out in a gentrified ass
neighborhood and then you know just live
life on a bicycle
and be a hipster yeah and I mean
realistically based off of even just
like supply land was a lot more
prevalent a generation ago and on top of
that like there's probably a lot more
opportunity to buy a house whereas
nowadays like for example um what is it
Hong Kong I believe is like one of those
densely populated populated places in
the world and they have like over 3
million people that live above like the
14th floor right I thought that Netflix
documentary and in how or whatever
inside out so it's like we live in a
generation where there's overpopulation
in all metropolitan areas so it's
impossible like you say it's impossible
to buy a house unless you're rich you're
rich which is already a growing rift
between like the super-rich versus like
the regular 90 most people in LA are
spending over half of their paycheck on
rent or mortgage or whatever it is and
it's like why like I don't know like for
the next 30 years you're going to be
spending this living
paycheck-to-paycheck
like most people are like [ __ ] that life
I rather just rent not have to deal with
it you know have other people take care
of the [ __ ] plumbing and all that
stuff and have a little bit more
spending money yeah now it's more common
even have housemates like it's not it's
not looked down upon and have a roommate
when you're like you know late 20s early
30s everyone else like cool I get it
like yeah you know it was like 30s and
you 20 or whatever I feel like this like
the whole social pressure to is
different we're like back in a day it's
kind of like you had to kind of after
you get married you got to buy a house
that's the thing you got to do you and
your wife or whatever
but I don't know if that's really the
[ __ ] now like if I know someone is
married but they're renting I don't oh
really you're doing that or you can't
come to the Country Club
do you think that thought comes from
because of just our industry and we're
surrounded by so many like-minded people
I mean I even know people who basic like
my older friends that don't work in
entertainment and all that stuff like
they're trying to save money and they're
still living with their parents or
combining forces with them or whatever
and they're in their 30s so I feel like
I mean if you if you really think about
it right a decent home out here is going
to cost you the range of 600 to 800
thousand dollars and if it's a really
nice neighborhood it's close to a
million yeah yes and the house is not
even regular house yeah houses built in
the 40s to 60s and it's got a [ __ ] ton
of issues one bathroom yeah it's small
ass rooms whatever and it's close to a
million dollars and it's like that's no
place I mean oh no it doesn't make any
sense even in the hood like my parents
home is in East LA and it's so good but
their property is going for a million
I'm like who the [ __ ] would pay I would
never pay that for this area and people
draw their own free-throw line with a
spray paint can that type of yeah yeah
throwing weed and bushes like there's a
battery room but I don't know there's
just me but I feel like a generation or
Millennials if you will like there's a
little bit more of a yo love mentality
for life yeah right when you see it in
pop culture and the music you see it and
like this kind of like maybe we live in
like the generation Armageddon or you
don't really think about like future
future you kind of feel like Yolo right
so you just do what you can while you
can and I'm not saying like that's the
best way to go about it I just feel like
that's like a lot of what this
generation is like and it's also a
generation of when they were in school
deciding what they were going to do
after school there were no jobs so it's
a generation of create what you want to
do yeah so I think because of that yeah
like if you're an entrepreneur you're
forced to be an entrepreneur then the
last thing you're thinking of is getting
married buying a house having kids
because you're like I'm trying to pursue
these passions so cuz I remember like I
was right at the
of going into corporate America and then
when the market crashed I just I
remember that whole transition where
people are like clogged I don't know I
have a degree I'm highly qualified but
there's no jobs for me so then it's like
well we got to create our own lemonade
stand so I think that we all have to
take that into account there's a lot of
entrepreneurial people in the Millennial
people almost everybody yeah so many but
I think everything has changed even the
past 10 years like our jobs weren't jobs
but yeah all of us right now we they
didn't exist back then and even now like
I don't think that we want to have the
same lives as our parents and like I
thought I was going to get married at 23
when I was younger on yeah when I was in
high school I go my mom gone there this
age she had kids by 25 like I'm not
gonna get married and I'm like
30-something I don't want kids until
like 36 like um things everyone I feel
like that around me is the same way too
there's no like that's not true so I'm I
eat my [ __ ] avocado so with the toast
egg yeah yeah so Tim was saying that you
know on the dream of owning your own
home is still possible but this
generation needs to come back on
unnecessary scheduled elections it just
depends on what your values are it
depends on what your values is some
people want to eat out every day or they
want to try some new [ __ ] every day
that's that's what this one to them let
them do this yeah and you see that
they're not saving up for that they
might have a eat out every day account
okay there was this um like super crazy
I don't know if he was an investment
banker or some kind of super successful
guy and then he decided like he just
wanted to continue surfing in Brazil so
he just up and left and he lives like
right on over the family right yeah
after he like made like 12 million when
we got you yeah well I mean he said so
he can do it comfortably but then that's
what gives them happiness it's just that
surfing every day and that was like 70
years old but he's ripped and buff yeah
I mean there's just it depends on what
you value like there's there's this
other guy who was a stockbroker or
whatever but
now he works with the Martha not Martha
Stewart what's her name the Indian maybe
Hannah no no mom mom Oh Theresa mom and
mother teresa's yeah not boss yeah
mother Theresa has like these different
institutes right where it's like there's
the last place where people go when they
have like leprosy they're dying and
there's just trickling no hope for this
people it's [ __ ] up but he goes there
and he has a lot of joy and just taking
care of people and he doesn't need
income like he you know I don't know if
he went there set like he just all he
does is just takes care of people and he
wants to like be that person before you
know they're dying and I'm just like
damn so really it just depends you know
like who's to say that you have to fit
the mold I'll give a [ __ ] here's the
thing certain from this animal he looks
like Justin Timberlake's Australian
really a last meal Patrick you like here
together
hybrid oh yeah for sure he looks young
Neil Patrick Timberlake yeah so wait is
he a millennial talking about
Millennials he is a millionaire um he's
35 years old
oh my god he's so young at the end of
the day all he's talking about is self
discipline because there's a lot of
people out there who dream of having a
dream home but they have no discipline
to get there because they just can't
control what they do every day is
probably just super exposed to a lot of
those people yeah so he's probably just
saying like y'all buy too much avocado
toast because like you talk about your
dreams but you don't [ __ ] follow them
so maybe that's that's what he's saying
yeah but then it just sounds like he's
making fun of people for not being rich
I don't think that's the case
thanks for watching just kidding news
guys don't forget to comment down below
we want to hear what you say only it's
positive remember that to watch more
videos go up here baby baby
[Music]